let me show you how it begins all right
we the first term is zero when you see a
new number the next term is zero so we
saw a zero but it was the first one so
the next term is zero we have seen a
zero before we saw it one minute ago and
when you've seen the number before the
next term is how far back how long ago
was it since you saw it so we saw it one
step back so the next term is one so now
what's the next term have we seen a one
before no so the next term is zero have
we seen a zero before yes how long ago
two steps ago so the next term is two
we've not seen a two before right so we
get a zero and we have seen a zero
before it was two steps ago and we have
seen a two before it was two steps ago
so we get another two and we have seen a
two before it was one step ago now for
the first time something really
interesting is happening we have seen a
one before but it was one two three four
five six steps back so we get a six and
we haven't seen a six before obviously
so the next term is a zero
well we've seen a zero before and it was
one two three four five steps back so we
get a five for the first time so the
next term is a zero again and then we
get a two and so on that is Vanek
sequence the obvious questions are what
happens
do we see every number how fast does it
grow what can we say about it we keep
asking these same questions over and
over again and this room always reminds
me of a poem by a gene Beaumont which is
called afraid so and it sort of goes
like this is it starting to rain
afraid so is this going to hurt are we
out of coffee it's the car totaled will
this leave a scar and so on the title is
afraid so I was thinking there are so
many questions we asked about these
sequences so the poem here would be
called
No what's the next term don't know how
fast does it grow don't know does every
number appear when someone just comes up
with a cool sequence like this and
there's all these don't knows whose job
is it to find out or does it you know
well this is one of the great things
about being an editor of the Oh a is
this sequence came in it was a
submission and one of the pleasures the
editors don't get paid but they do get
to see these sequences when they come in
for the first time and so you look at
them you say boy that's a really great
sequence I'm gonna analyze that before
somebody else does you see so many
sequences in here why is this one yeah I
think it's lovely well partly because
it's it's really quite unpredictable and
so of course one of the first things you
do is you look at the graph let me see
if I can give you a sketch so there's a
0 and a 0 and a 1 and a 0 and there too
but basically what happens it goes and
then drops down to zero and it grows and
so on and if you look at a lot of terms
it tends to look a bit like this if you
close your eyes and squint it sort of
fills up the whole triangle it seems
that it's growing about linearly if you
look at this line that goes through the
top it seems to have slope 1 in other
words the interim is about n but we
can't prove that that's one of the many
things we can't prove about this so
there is one thing we can prove it keeps
growing it could be that after a while
we don't see any new numbers there are
no more zeros if the maximum number that
ever appeared was a hundred then after
we see a hundred there won't be any more
zeros because there won't be any more
new numbers and the argument is very
very pretty
you say suppose there's some number
let's call it m maybe it's a hundred or
maybe it's a million which is the
maximum number that appears ever in this
sequence now what that would mean
is since the sequence is defined by how
far back you look for the last term that
if the miss number is say a hundred you
would never have to look back more than
a hundred terms in order to know the
complete history from that point on
everything would be determined but then
you say if we only have to look back M
terms or M plus 1 terms and each of
those terms is in the range 1 to M then
there would only be m to the M possible
terms supposing that there is a biggest
number and we look at a chunk of length
M that determines everything from that
point on but then you say there are only
m to the M different chunks so one of
them will have to repeat so the sequence
will be periodic so from a certain point
on the sequence will repeat but that
can't happen you want to see the proof I
think it's quite nice so here's the
sequence and this part is the period and
then it repeats from then on it just
keeps repeating over and over again and
let me prove that can't happen let's
look at this chunk say it begins with X
dot dot dot and it ends with Z in the
next period it's the same thing it just
repeats X to Z and so on there might be
other copies of Z in the period so let's
look at the first time we see a Z so
this is the first copy of Z in the
period and let's look at the term that
comes after it and let's call it a now
what that means is by the rule the
definition of the sequence is that this
a means last time we saw the Z was a
steps back that's what this a means ok
now let's move to the previous period so
we have the Z and we have the a it's
exactly the same as this but this a
means that this Z actually appeared a
steps back so it was here so that means
the period didn't begin there the first
period it began one step earlier which
is a contradiction
that can't happen so the sequence keeps
growing and that's about the only thing
we know about it there's no maximum we
know for sure there's no maximum number
there are more and more zeros beyond
that we know almost nothing and there
are a number of other questions I could
I should mention I mean for instance
does every number appear don't know okay
folks here's one for you how many ways
can you arrange plus and minus signs
between these numbers and get a result
that's divisible by three this is just
one of the many daily challenges from
brilliant and it comes with plenty more
interesting chat and discussion as you
can see here in fact all the daily
challenges are great I really like this
recent one about bikes and tracks check
it out
brilliant of course have sponsored
today's episode there great supporters
of numberphile and their collection of
challenges quizzes and courses online
you can see them here they're just
fantastic there's plenty of cool free
stuff to check out but also their
premium subscription gives you access to
everything you can get 20% off that
subscription by going to brilliant org
slash numberphile and make sure you
check out those daily challenges
you can even binge on all the previous
ones that's kind of like a mathematical
box set the thing that happens in your
brain when you read a number that you're
familiar with is different to what
happens when you read a number that you
are unfamiliar with